when it comes to parks playgrounds and
open spaces as locals we know the city
of las vegas is second to none
now the word is out wallet hub ranked
100 of the largest cities in the united
states for their commitment to
recreation and las vegas came out ready
for it number one
so parks and open spaces are essential
to the health and well-being of our
community
those spaces provide a variety of
programs for all ages and abilities
and they also support the mission of the
city which is to build community to make
life better
we headed over to baskin park to find
out if any of the park regulars were
surprised to hear this news the
overwhelming answer was no surprise at
all
we do have a lot of great parts a lot of
great water parts
things to do for the kids you can
barbecue you know you know just have a
great time and we already been here two
hours and they're already wanting to
stay longer
i do believe that vegas is a beautiful
place and it has a really good
recreation park i think so i love it i
love the city
the city boasts 80 parks more per square
mile than the other cities as well as
community senior and cultural centers
but it's not just the number of parks
and centers it's the variety of
activities they offer
we do have our traditional amenities at
our parks like cover picnic areas
covered playgrounds but we also have
inclusive playground equipment at some
of our parks that support all abilities
we also have basketball courts tennis
courts pickleball courts dog parks
splash pads we have 28 of those and we
also have programming in parks like
volunteers and parks which helps with
park cleanups and beautification events
and also our pop-up mobile recreation
program which goes out into the
community and takes recreational
activities to the public
wallethub reminds us of the importance
of city parks in their report they say
staying active isn't just good for your
health it's also good for your wallet
one of the best ways to maintain an
active lifestyle is to choose a city
that encourages and facilitates
recreation
research shows having a park near your
house adds to your home's value helps
people stay fit saving them up to
fifteen hundred dollars a year and
reduces overall cost of air pollution by
nearly four billion dollars a year now
while all of that is great these locals
just know parks mean family time and
that is more valuable than anything we
drove down here and he fell in love with
this i came back today they love the
water park right here they've been
playing they like the slides they got me
playing with them
we haven't been able to test out
everything but we love it